[Applause]
okay
guys let's have the conversation let us
do
it uh let's talk about some mobiles um
this is gonna happen uh more and more
and more so get used to this
can you explain exactly what happened
yes so let's just go through a couple
things i actually have a couple notes so
i can get this
held thing right um
okay ready let's start again all right
guys let's talk about it
uh there's one story right now everybody
is obviously discussing uh simone biles
and uh let's just get to the bottom of
it uh so simone biles
has removed herself from the uh the
group
um event in gymnastics uh
as of this morning recording this
wednesday she's also removed herself
from the individual all-around so she
did which she was the defending champion
of
uh she still potentially can do
the individual events within it right
but the all-around she's removed herself
from uh
she was supposed to win that uh she's
regarded as the greatest to ever do it
she said the reason why she did it was
uh her mental wasn't there said that she
was stressed out and she felt immense
pressure
uh she did a vault the other day and uh
she got lost in the air
and uh she felt scared for physical
safety she didn't want to leave on a
stretcher
and uh she just doesn't trust her body
and she didn't want to
hurt herself and you can't hurt yourself
yeah you know i mean that sport is
dangerous you know we see girls doing it
so we assume it's not dangerous but it
is
an absolutely [ __ ] terrifying thing
you're doing backflips laying on your
head
break your neck you never walk again
right it's it's some real [ __ ] so the
question is
what's gonna happen uh people are saying
a million different things um obviously
there's this discussion whether she's
brave uh whether she's selfish
the selfish discussion first happened
when it came to like the uh the group
all around because by her removing
herself the u.s
ends up uh getting the silver right and
since she's the best female gymnast of
all time
yeah you're going to put your team at a
disadvantage because something you're
personally going for
people called it selfish then also
people are like oh you're taking your
mental health seriously so
you're being incredibly brave let's have
a discussion
um selfish or brave
uh if her mental state is affecting her
physical
ability i don't think you can call her
selfish
because if she physically is
incapable of doing the things that help
her team
by removing herself i think it's
selfless
i think that there are selfish people
especially in sports like basketball
that are injured but still want to be
out there for glory
i think that's selfish okay you're
hurting your [ __ ] team because you
want to be the guy that hits the last
shot
right yeah you know um you are not in
any way assisting your team winning but
you want to be part of that [ __ ] game
you got the narrative my team needs me
that's where all my team needs me i got
to be there but even if it's not true
your team needs to win
your team needs to win and you're
hurting your team from winning i mean a
lot of people knock kobe for this
they're like yo kobe towards the end of
his career r.i.p they're like what
you're doing is selfish you're breaking
down these other players and you don't
have the ability to dominate the game
like you once did
yeah so i i don't think that what she
did was
uh selfie especially when she removed
herself from the uh
girls all-around event right okay um
because
uh that's just her she's the defending
her
championship or her last olympic gold
medal the last person to do that i think
it was like in 1960 or something like
that
right crazy amount of times went by so
everybody was gearing up for that
everybody is really excited for that
is she brave not in the least
i don't think there's anything brave
about this i think that you know i think
there's like a
the specific definition of bravery and i
and i wrote this down
uh was is the ability to confront
something painful or difficult uh
or dangerous without any fear
she's doing the exact opposite she
cannot confront it
she's succumbing to it she's saying my
mental
is too [ __ ] up for me to compete
at the level that i'm accustomed to
competing in so i have to withdraw the
bravery
is the scrutiny the fact that you feel
like you're letting your country down on
some level it's
exiting the olympics even though you are
the best gymnast probably ever
jordan if he made it a mental health
thing was like yo i'm walking away
it's bravery required from that because
the whole [ __ ] league david sterling
whoever's gonna be like yo this is
costing us a lot of money
you bet paid a lot of money nike's gonna
be putting pressure on what the [ __ ] is
going on
that's where the bravery comes in you're
looking at it strictly physically
she is this death-defying sport she's
not participating in it that can't be
brave
the bravery could be okay so she so
there i hear what you're saying the
scrutiny she faces
i understand what people are saying like
it's brave of you to leave the sport
knowing what you're going to go up
against
or not compete knowing what you're going
to go up against how many people you're
going to let down blah blah blah i
understand that
uh so maybe in that regard it's brave
but
i think it's the antithesis of bravery
and going i can't handle the pressure
and i'm not going to find a way to
persevere under this pressure and that's
what the olympics is about and that is
also under pressure yeah it is the it is
the epitome of pressure this happens not
once every year
not once every month this is the
tournament that defines greatness it
happens once every four years nobody
gives a flying [ __ ] about gymnastics
until
one week every four years now they give
a [ __ ] about it and it's your job to
perform under pressure
right now pressure that
not only the media put on you that you
put on you yeah and i think that a lot
of people are undermining this
when you start walking around with a
sequence leotard
that has a goat on it when you start
having goat on your sandals
when you start referring to yourself as
the goat
the greatest of all time you add that
pressure i saw an interview clip
where someone said can you be beaten and
then she said she smiled and she was
like
i don't know and it's like yeah that's
putting a lot of pressure on you
when i saw that i was like she's not
going to win the gold this year you
are interesting i remember thinking and
it's not i just i feel like i see
athletes hit that point mentally
sometimes
where they're really like i don't know
if i could be beaten i think i'm kind of
and it just seems like in my mind's like
recollection those people always
end up falling there's a real quick
about that discussion uh to add on to
that
is that there was discussion whether the
olympic scoring committee was racist
because the way that olympic scoring
goes for
or just scoring in general goes for
gymnastics is the
the height of your score like as high as
your score can possibly go is based on
the difficulty of a trick
and she was doing tricks that
nobody had done before they were
literally called the biles
so they didn't know how to score them so
what they were going to do is cap the
scoring at where they were already
so that let's say this is just i don't
know anything about [ __ ] gymnastics
but let's say two front flips
gave you 10 points back in the day and
she was like well now i'm doing three
points
three front flips the olympic scoring
committee was like we just
cap things at 10. she's like now you're
giving somebody who i'm competing with
an advantage over me because they're
doing something less difficult and
they're still getting the same score as
me
so i'm not rewarded for taking this
extra risk right so then there was a
conversation about whether that's racist
or not it's like everything is gearing
you're asking for this you're calling
yourself the goat you're saying i'm way
better i don't know if i can be beat
you're doing all this i'm sure people
are in your head telling you that you
are the goat
you haven't been beaten the last time
you lost you were 16 years old she is
the goat
she's the goat there's no question but
that adds to the pressure that you feel
yeah and the more you embrace that the
more people are going to be like
eyeballs on you and that's great if you
can pull it off
but that's you're putting a lot on
yourself in addition to what everybody
else is putting on you
and i'm sure she didn't start the hey
that's racist scoring conversation
once that enters that's other people's
pressure so i get that but
i think her saying [ __ ] like i don't
know if i could be beaten
that puts a lot of pressure on yourself
when you're putting the goat on your
clothes by all means do that
just understand the pressure you put on
yourself when you do it i think go go
out
so i do think we need to wait and see
exactly why she dropped out i know she's
saying mental health now but i
have a feeling there's something else to
it i think she may be a little injured
and she doesn't want to admit that
and that's is affecting her ability to
perform the way she is and so she's
going out
this way because that's way easier to
admit push back way easier to admit
i'm hurt then i'm mentally not right we
can't really say she's
like not brave for being able to live up
to the moment because she has got the
goal before
she's done this so she's she's got to
the mountaintop and
five years ago it was a different
pressure there she can acknowledge that
oh
something's off within her either her
mental or her physical
where she can't perform i do think it's
brave of her to
back out even though everybody wants to
see her go everybody's injured
nobody's healthy come on bro no no no no
no wait everybody's making all these
[ __ ] excuses and if this was a male
athlete
none of y'all would be saying [ __ ] if
this was tom brady white man
jordan if this was kobe bryant if it was
anybody yes and
all those play all those people if you
had a let me finish
if you had a real conversation with any
of those players right there if they had
if tom brady came up to you if michael
jordan came up to you
if kobe came up to you and they asked
what was going on right here you think
they're gonna be like oh she's having a
rough day mentally she
said oh her foot hurts a little bit they
say no you grit and bear it you push
through that [ __ ]
because we are [ __ ] alpha dogs and we
steamroll past these weak [ __ ]
who can't handle the moment
we handle the moment that's what we do
and this is the moment
and they are salivating for this they
cannot wait
they can't wait for the opportunity to
look at every one of those other
gymnasts or look at every one of those
other athletes
and go i'm going to bite your [ __ ]
head off
that's what they live for and she's not
living for this and i think there's a
different pressure because i don't think
simone biles
and maybe i'm not remembering correctly
but i don't think simone bios was
um the the favored winner at that time
i think she was i remember watching i
thought she was there you're talking
about her like this is [ __ ] crazy
yeah that was the olympics before and
then i think by this one it was kind of
recognized by last time i think was kind
of recognized like
this the [ __ ] girl i thought it was
gabby douglas and then simone came out
and shocked everybody
and then we were like oh my god who is
this and then she goes back check me i'm
pretty sure gabby was like that
nine years ago and then five years ago
that she was still whatever but
people were looking at simone like this
is [ __ ] crazy what this girl can do
it's like at this age it's crazy
but it was still like unprecedented
right like the the expectations weren't
there because she hadn't won
that's true the olympic goal and now
she's seizing the moment right and it's
like
when you're tom brady and you gotta go
for your seventh [ __ ] gold
and i wish we could use female uh uh
examples right like
serena williams or something like that
like when you've already won a bunch of
these competitions
and you're going in as the killer and
then you kill that's different
when you're like the young new kid and
nobody has an expectation like whoa what
a wild ride there's no pressure
go out there throw it okay osaka did
this in the
french tournament and she broke down in
the olympics too no but i'm saying like
she withdrew from it because of how her
mental health or whatever the case was
yeah but i'm saying like that's and a
person who's at the top of their game
we knew she was about to go in there and
kill and she's like you know what no my
mental health is more important and she
backed up
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i need to make sure your dicks stay hard
damn right
okay i know that sounded funky but i
meant what i said there's only one
company that's gonna make sure you
satisfy your girl
satisfy your side chick satisfy that
girl that you're super nervous to sleep
with you haven't done it yet just yet
but you're about to
and that is blue chew same active
ingredients as inside cialis and viagra
but this is the true
the only one we [ __ ] with is the one
that you should [ __ ] with as well okay
because we are basically married men on
this podcast you know we're doing
something right all right so you're
going to go to bluetooth.com you're
going to use the promo code
flagrant you're going to get that [ __ ]
for
free okay you get the sample for free
all you got to do is pay 5
shipping okay you're going to get it for
free try it for free
hard dick the best dick you ever deliver
in your life for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars
shipping when you go to bluetooth.com
use the promo code flagrant that is a
no-brainer
now we're getting back to this exclusive
patreon clip that you can get
at patreon.com
i think it can be it yeah it's brave to
say to the
in the face of like the whole country
you know i got to focus on my mental
health
i also think you can bring a decent
amount of this pressure on yourself
that's [ __ ] up your head and maybe
you could have thought that through
before you're saying [ __ ] like i don't
know if i can be beaten
and putting a [ __ ] goat to knock
somebody for being confident
i'm not knocking you for being confident
i'm just saying there is also a
responsibility that hey that's what i
did and i own that but that puts a
pressure on as an athlete you have a
responsible
responsibility uh as i can't speak as an
athlete you are responsible for your
mental as well
what separates the greats is their
ability to control their mental state
that's what makes them great what makes
reggie miller [ __ ] amazing and it
breaks my heart as a knicks fan
is that when the going gets tough when
everybody else's [ __ ] tightens
his [ __ ] loosens up he's ready to go
pass me to rock
i can't wait you know so i think i think
in these types of moments
you can't create a caveat for an athlete
this has to be a ding because what
separates them is the
mental is part of it nobody got nervous
then what's the big deal
why are you missing free throws at the
end of the game like be not being
nervous
being able to be stand up locked in
checked in at at the most important time
might be the defining characteristic of
a goat
okay so i won't say it's not a knock
i'm just saying two things can be right
at the same time it's like yes this
could be a knock on her
come on you should live up to the moment
but also it is also brave
because you know how many people want
you to perform and the fact that you're
putting yourself
yeah like we are doing the hard thing
this year's
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying so yeah
that's what's going on we acknowledge
that her stepping away
in the face of immense scrutiny is brave
yes because she knows that she has to
face that scrutiny and
facing that unbelievable like just
onslaught of criticism it's a lifetime
of it's a lot
now i will say this i think it's very
important
to recognize the more we start to
understand mental health and the more
that we give grace to mental health the
more that we're going to see this happen
but this is also a function of society
changing
right so it's like this is something
that we've created but our brains
haven't caught up to it yet
is simone biles under more pressure than
michael jordan i don't think so
but she's under more pressure 24 7.
michael jordan had to deal with
sportscenter he had to deal with sports
illustrated once a week or whenever that
[ __ ] came out once a week
once a month in the morning
but it was very easy to check out yes
right it's not like you get a google
alert and all of a sudden you're
trending
every time you go type in anything into
google you type you just want to know
what happened in the news
yes right there's going to be something
about you yeah it's easy to unplug from
social media
but at a certain point you're going to
look at your phone and get a
notification your [ __ ] name is going
to be
sending you [ __ ] no they might be doing
it in a good way where they're like oh
look at this article about you but then
you're reading like
oh but she [ __ ] up this part and then
you're seeing the negative stuff yeah
your parents
your sisters your brothers your uncles
and they mean well but
all these people exactly like speaking
on behalf of you maybe they're doing
something [ __ ] up on the side now
you're getting criticized
right the story is always the famous
person's cousin yeah
right if they can attach you to fame at
any point in time and as you said this
is a sport that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about for
four years so it's like it goes from
nobody talking about
to 100. i'm the most talked about person
of this [ __ ] and i was i was hyped to
see someone biles i don't know anything
about gymnastics
i know her no she's the best oh that
[ __ ] is impressive to watch
yeah fly man but there was a quote to
what you were saying there was a quote
that i think shifty sent us maybe from
tim grover who was michael jordan's
personal trainer kobe bryant's personal
trainer yeah the foremost killers
mentally we've ever had probably
he said something like winning takes you
to hell and if you quit that's where
you'll stay
so i'm not saying what i agree or
disagree with i'm saying the mentality
of those guys yeah this is going to what
andrew was saying the mentality of those
guys is i don't quit i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah she quit she quit and she quit for
mental issues like i don't want to
i don't want to belittle that she quit
because she couldn't control her mentals
in the most
important part of her competitive career
at the olympics
like you can't undercut that in any way
and i understand that people love her
and care about her and concerned for her
mental health
but if that is an important component in
being a successful athlete
and you don't live up to that it's no
different than somebody being injured
all the time
yeah i bet greg oden would have been a
great nba player if his knees held up
they didn't they didn't hold up
and that's a knock on greg odin they
didn't hold up when you needed them to
so criticizing her for this i don't
think is rude or mean or hurtful
it's no different than criticizing some
nba player for not being able to shoot
well
yeah and not be able to dribble it's
just a fact
and i can support your decision and
still be a little critical of it hey
you gotta do that man absolutely like
like andrew said this is a death defying
sport if you injure yourself you're
[ __ ] nobody wants that
take care of your mental health also
i think i could be a little critical of
a decision i think the issue with her is
that socially we look at mental health
and we don't see it as an extension of
their physical body like we don't see it
as like an extension of their athletic
game we see it as like a personal
decision
yeah so like oh she just chose to be
weak instead of like
oh no her mental was objectively like
the knee situation
like you can't choose for your knee to
be injured but the public perception is
like oh she's choosing for her brain to
be
no i i understand the public feels that
way i don't i don't think
of it that way i think that she has the
responsibility to
control her mental state and do all the
work leading up to this to make sure
she's on point right
like if it was a joint in her knee like
she should be doing physical therapy and
100 percent care exactly if you know
your knees are weak you're gonna uh
like increase the muscle mass around
your knee right
increase your calves increase your quads
increase your anything you possibly your
hamstrings to take the pressure off that
knee
so if you know that you get nervous in
moments like this make sure you're doing
the work
like there are certain people uh jamal
murray right jamal murray did a
meditation his whole life when he goes
to the line the free-throw line he
meditates he tries to drop his heart
rate he tries to get in a state where
he's not really thinking i think he's
like a 90
free throw shooter you know so it's like
understand what you have to do
and conquer that part of the game but
the mental is part of the game
so to just write it off like oh yeah her
mentals weren't there so now that's not
a knock in any way
no no no it's a knock and it's a big
[ __ ] knock
especially when you walk around with
goat [ __ ] everywhere because the goats
don't let that happen and i know people
can say hey jordan walked away
because his mental wasn't there that's
true
and that's a good knock that's a good
knock
his mental wasn't there he couldn't
focus on the game we look at it and we
go
oh he was just bored with it yeah he
didn't really care blah blah blah and
maybe that was the case
maybe he just didn't want to play
basketball that's what we believe
because he's such a [ __ ] killer
maybe it was too much for him did he say
that i think he was just like
my brain was elsewhere like my father
died i didn't have anything to focus on
no challenges left and you're right
we should call we should call that out
the same way i think that we as
basketball fans look at him
and we're like oh lebron played had a
bad series against the mavs because he
mentally but he's weak
jordan walked away for damn near two
years in his prime and
his after a three-peat yeah he didn't
want to defend his title i'm done
i mean if we're going to criticize
lebron i think that's a great example if
we're going to criticize
lebron's mental lapse yeah in that
series where
delante west was allegedly just crushing
his mom's puss
i think that it's completely reasonable
to criticize some old biles yeah for a
mental lapse
and i don't think that we should be like
you know sexist by holding women to a
lower standard
if this was a dude if this was a dude
what i i don't think we should if this
was a male gymnast
this conversation was the most sexist
thing i forgot what he said what did he
say
uh women's sports oh women yeah
if this was a male gymnast yo be honest
if this is a male gymnast that said i
have to step away
from this sport i have to step away from
the sword i can't do this because
my mentals aren't there do you
understand the ridicule
get on those uneven bars bro yeah get on
it saddle up dog let's do it immediately
uneven like your state of mind get in
there exactly
just go like this on the rings why is
that [ __ ] hard prance around
you're in tights the [ __ ] is wrong with
you you [ __ ] what do you mean your
mental stays weak you've been called a
[ __ ] your whole life you know when kevin
love stepped away during the regular
season very low stakes from the cavs and
then when he came back isaiah thomas was
like
nah man he's not for us he's not a part
of the team he took care of his mental
health his teammates were like
certain teammates also kyrie we rip him
every time oh my mental health is weird
i need to step away from the game
shut the [ __ ] up get back out there and
play simone is just goat status
and she does what the goats do that's
one way that's one way looking i don't
think uh kevin love is a goat but i hear
what you're saying
i think that like i i just think that
there's a lot of sexism at play here man
like there's a lot now people say oh
should we hold simone to the standards
of men or should we just hold men to the
standards of simone
which is letting them get off the hook
if their mental game isn't there
and taking like some gen like generosity
with them i i mean like look i'm more of
a savage
but western society is going to
gravitate towards
understanding these mental conditions in
the same way we understand physical ones
and we're going to have way more grace
right are they going to do that in
[ __ ] china
no right they're going to be absolute
savages but what do you mean you're sad
what is sad we don't do sad
yeah we tell you what to feel yeah you
feel happy you feel happy
i am happy go flip that's it yeah you
know what helps depression
winning winning go out there and win
okay so i think that
as we create a society that's way more
understandable it's going to be better
for people people are going to
live a more you know joyful life it's
better for life
but it's worse for competition and we
will start to get smoked the more that
we understand and then we'll
just be essentially what europe is
europe's not good at anything right like
realistically what are they good at uh i
mean that sincerely
i mean i mean soccer because they're the
only ones who play it i've thought about
soccer they're not
good at soccer the players
from countries that don't have that
grace
for mental weakness yeah right the the
the offspring of those people who come
to a new country and take those values
of
we're not letting you cry and [ __ ]
about this go out there and kill
all the african parents of the kids on
the french nationals do you think
they're allowing a mental illness or
mental weakness or
or a rough mental state to stop them
from succeeding why are you gay
you're not gay right like so
don't get me wrong it's probably much
more pleasant people understand people
are happier for sure
they're way happier in europe it is
better for the average person
and what is better for the average as
you increase the average
you decrease the extremes one extreme
could be the incredibly depressed the
suicidal
maybe those are decreased maybe those
people are pulled back in because what
they're going through is understood
right there's some compassion for it you
know what else you decrease
the psycho's on the other end right you
decrease
the michael jordans you decrease the
kobe bryant
i think that's just you decrease the
jeff bezos
there's none of them come out of europe
and i'm not just trying to like knock
you up here
we're gonna go i'm very excited i want
to tour europe i think it's amazing
those people are happy they're happy and
we should learn from them and i hope as
america gets older we actually gravitate
in that direction i think that's just
the general trend of society agreed
and i think at one point they were the
most savage i mean they were going
around the world
you have to colonize objectively the
most savage yeah the most savage people
yeah they're all here because of how
invented capitalism invented colonialism
all that [ __ ] and then they're like
alright let's just
share the world you have to get access
to realize it doesn't really solve
anything
yes and we're still in the process you
need excess nor to get the
economic conditions in order to bring
everyone up so then make everything oh
that's also interesting yeah
you